as the white house tries to get the
southern border under control fox news
with an exclusive look at how cartels
are taking advantage of the chaos they
are making a ton of money
border officials try to stop drugs and
smuggled migrants from entering the
country
lieutenant christopher alvarez of the
texas department of public safety
is on the front lines of the border and
joins me now sir good morning to you
here's some statistics from operation
lone star texas alone
criminal arrests almost 700 marijuana
seizures
5 000 pounds cocaine and meth firearms
currency seizures more than
a million it's all there lieutenant and
it's all coming our way
good morning bill thanks for having me
you're correct so the numbers don't lie
the numbers speak for themselves um
we're we are continuing to see an
increase in illegal crossing as well as
criminal activity
as as you see there with those stats
weapons drugs
uh currency uh pursuits
it's just there's a variety of different
criminal aspects that are taking place
here right now along the southern border
right now well there's one report that
you see
11 million dollars worth of drugs in a
48-hour period it just blows the mind
i don't know if you heard vice president
kamala harris over the weekend a sample
from what she said on cnn
on sunday the kind of work that has to
happen is the diplomatic work
that we've been engaged in in term
including my calls to the president of
mexico
the president of guatemala but it's not
going to be solved overnight part of the
problem is that under the previous
administration they pulled out
essentially a lot of what had been the
continuum of work
and it it essentially came to a
standstill lieutenant what do you think
of that answer
bill what i can say on that is she's
correct as far as it's not gonna
it's likely to be an overnight solution
but it does take
federal government support to help our
federal partners the state of texas will
answer the call and we always answer the
call
but it does take support from the
federal government and
come see it for yourself you got to come
see it for yourself come speak to the
great men and women
who are working the front lines who see
it for themselves day in and day out
who risk their lives to protect the
border for the community and for the
citizens of texas
we founded our fox polling u.s border
security compared to two years ago i
know you can't see this sir i'll read it
to you
is it better or worse or the same 46
say now it is worse than june of 2018.
kamala harris said she go to central
america in june
what's wrong with now
you know right now bill i can tell you
from speaking with the men and women who
are working the front lines
our federal partners this year by far
any previous years has been a a
significant increase in legal crossings
and criminal activity and the numbers
speak for themselves and the men and
women who work
this operation day in and day out can
speak on it as well
lieutenant good luck down there you need
a lot of help
thank you for being here you bet from
the state of texas with an issue
that is too large to manage now given
the way it has gone over the past three
i cannot for the life of me understand
the first woman vice president not
seizing this opportunity
to do i mean not just on immigration but
like to drive on lots of different
issues and
you can travel safely everybody's doing
it and she has a private
plane and uh protocols and the ability
to go and do something i just feel like
they are
really missing an opportunity here as we
said last hour you can fly to an airport
have a meeting and a hangar
come back and be perfectly safe with
covet with regard to the drugs
uh coming into the country it's a big
problem um
you you can see that drug cartels the
amount of money and power they have
they know how to run this business and
they will get
the lines of transport
for these illegal drugs across the
border and into american cities quicker
than you know
they know how to make the money and
they're doing it they do in fact
in national review today online nicole
bishop and chip roy congressman chip roy
and nicole
she's a former prosecutor as well they
write about how the cartels have
basically seized the moment and we are
not
which is a huge problem moving on now as
president biden completes his first 100
days in office congresswoman alexandre
ocasio-cortez
weighing in on how he's done with those
progressive campaign prompts